business owners in North Carolina's
Outer Banks are suing the construction
company that caused a massive power
outage tens of thousands of people were
forced to evacuate during the height of
the busy summer season businesses say
they're losing thousands of dollars a
day in 2015 visitors spent more than 1
billion dollars in the Outer Banks
cruise damaged the power lines Thursday
while working to replace a major bridge
the mistake out of power to Oracle and
Hatteras islands DeMarco Morgan is in
the Outer Banks on P Island with what is
being done to restore power DeMarco good
morning good morning Charlie and just to
give you an idea of just how fast crews
are working take a look at these polls
right here behind me you can see seven
of the plan 210 polls that were set up
within the last 24 hours they'll carry
the new transmission line that will
supply power to the affected areas all
along while construction workers right
here behind me are working to repair
that last damaged cable underground
North Carolina Governor Roy Cooper
toured Hatteras Island on Monday
including the construction site where
crews are scrambling to fix a damaged
underground transmission line this
company made a mistake and cut these
cables and it is time to get it fixed
utility providers have been ferrying in
massive generators to help power homes
and businesses for submitting a 6000
people still on Hatteras and Ocracoke
Islands since Thursday nearly 50,000
visitors have been forced to evacuate
during the islands busy summer vacation
months police are turning away new
visitors until power is restored when
the population leaves here the economy
is essentially gone and shut down and a
class-action lawsuit filed against the
construction company responsible for the
blackout local business owners say they
have suffered thousands of dollars in
losses they allege pcl civil
constructors claimed it could save the
state 60 million dollars by using
innovative construction methods and an
accelerated schedule we are about a week
away from going under
Deborah Scalia says the disruption has
caused her surf shop up to seven
thousand dollars per day that money we
need to get through the winter day
here and we just don't have it governor
Cooper hopes business owners like Scalia
can eventually be reimbursed we don't
know what the legal landscape is at the
moment but what people are concentrated
on right now is getting things on and up
and walking as soon as we possibly can
now governor Cooper declared a state of
emergency last Thursday that means that
relief funds could be made available to
local businesses here meantime we
reached out to vcl civil constructors
about the lawsuit after hours we have
yet to receive a comment Margaret
DeMarco thank you